In order to scan a website you first need to add it to BurpSuite Enterprise.
Adding a site's details makes it possible to take full advantage of BurpSuite Enterprise's
analytics features which enable you to track issues with your site over time.
Most of BurpSuite Enterprise's data and configuration options are managed on a per site basis.
Now you can add as many sites as you wish at no extra cost.
BurpSuite Enterprise Edition licensing is based around the number of concurrent scans
that you can run and not the number of sites added to the system.
Please also note that your scanning machine must be able to access the site that you want
to scan and for more information on allowing access please see our documentation configuring
your environment network and firewall settings.
Okay to begin with we navigate to our sites page and in the top right corner we'll see
the new site button.
Here we can add the site details so we want to give it a unique name.
In this case we'll just call it test and then we can add it to one of our folders.
If we leave this at the default root folder the site is created at the top level of the site
tree.
Next we can add our site scope.
So firstly this is going to be the highest level URL that we want to include in scans of
this site and all sub directories of that URL will be scanned by default.
So we can add our URL in.
This is PortsWigger's deliberately vulnerable test web application which you are free to
use for the purposes of your own testing.
So by default this is going to be scanned using HTTP and HTTPS or if we were to specify
a protocol in the URL we can select scan using my specified protocol just to pick one of those.
If we expand the additional options here for site scope we'll see an option for included
URLs and excluded URLs.
So for included URLs if there are URLs that are part of the same web application but not
contained under the specified site URL we can add it here to bring it into our scope for the
scan.
In contrast if there's elements of the application that we do not want to scan we can add that
to the excluded URLs list and that will be skipped during the scan.
Now we can move on to our site settings.
So firstly that's going to be our scan configuration that's used for the scans against this particular
application and we have two options here.
We can use the preset scan mode designed to get you up and running as quick as possible and
this ranges from a lightweight scan which will be completed within 15 minutes all the way
to deep which is going to get better coverage and understanding of the site security posture
but that will take longer in terms of the scan time.
If we want to create a custom configuration we can do so and add it to our library and that
will be accessible here.
There are also some built-in custom configurations that you can utilize out of the box and this
just changes the behavior of either the crawl or the audit in some way shape or form.
So perhaps we're limiting the crawl maximizing the audit doing something like a minimization
of false positives but you can also create your own enough complete control over those custom options.
Those are the required settings.
The remaining scan settings are optional but can be useful to get the most out of your scan.
So for example if we wanted to add authentication to our scan we can do so here.
Option one being a username and password.
So if you've got quite a basic single page login mechanism we can give it a label, add our username,
add our password and we locate that form during the scan or submit those credentials.
For anything more complex we would recommend our recorded login sequence.
You can learn about how this works with the link in product to the documentation but once you've got
that set up and recorded it'll generate a JSON file which is a sequence of events for logging in that the
crawler can follow and you can paste that here.
This is typically for anything more complex than a single form so single sign-on or multi-page login for example.
We can also specify our extensions. Extensions are available through the Burp BAP store.
Once added to your enterprise installation they'll be selectable from the list
and typically extensions will modify the behavior of the crawler in some way shape or form.
And finally if we set up a scanning pool which includes a dedicated scanning machine resource
we can allocate that here but by default it will just be added to the default pool.
Once we've set all our options we can click save and our site has been created.
We can then perform a pre-scan check which will perform a connection check against the provided URL
and give us a result and also if we added a recorded login sequence that will be replayed
and checked to ensure that we've logged in okay.
Now that your site has been created you can move on to running your first scan.
Please note that we recommend keeping a consistent scan configuration for each site that you add.
Changing the scan configuration can affect vulnerability trends over time
and cause Burp BAPS to Enterprise Edition to give inaccurate time estimates when scanning.
If you want to scan a site that you've already added with a new configuration we would recommend adding the
site again with the new configuration selected because as mentioned we don't limit the number of sites that you create.
Thank you.